[Music]
hey guys welcome to rogue theory it's a
new show that we're really excited about
here in rockstars we're bringing
together some of our favorite people and
the Nerdist sphere to hypothesize and
theorize and hungry eyes all the ices I
thought the topics and questions that
are in that nerdy zeitgeist right now
also we got a new set devon worked
really hard on it give it up for devin
he doesn't know that he worked on it
he's been doing it is in through his
nightmares but on this episode we're
gonna talk about marvel's re-release of
avengers endgame the big-time actor that
is supposedly maybe it'll definitely
probably joining the MCU and a potential
fixed ending of Game of Thrones alright
although some people think it doesn't
need any fixing just saying I don't know
and then also just whatever else comes
up any nerdy tangents this happens here
with me speaking of the Nerds that will
tangent with me on this panel are
Whitney van Landingham from nerd wire
our boy Sam basher host of only stupid
answers and also might be awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright so how are you guys doing
welcome sir first one welcome you guys
inaugurated it if that's a bird sounds
right do we have champagne that we can
smash on the set yes oh we no longer
keep champagne here because of what you
did I really yeah yeah we don't need to
go into that and we'll do that again
after the show but instead let's talk
about what's going on with this event
return game thing so Marvel Studios had
Kevin Feige announced a plan to
re-release Avengers end game again in
theaters with get ready a deleted scene
a little tribute and a few surprises so
probably after the credits so the first
like nerdy deep-dive question that I
have is is there any chance that this
isn't just a blatant attempt to make
sure that they defeat avatar at the box
office take a swing at this first but
it's just like you it feels like that
it's silly internet points that if this
movie gets more points that means the
thing we like more won cuz like avatar
right now everyone's like boo no one
wants these movies five to six more that
are coming out in the next 40 years no
one won't ask for these so we want do
you get paid in points I just exchange
them for anything I want really got a
switch over to favors and threats oh
it's definitely like it feels a little
feels a little cheap because immediately
when I heard that I wanted to buy a
ticket you know like I I want to I want
to contribute that I want to know what
else they're gonna give me but the same
time you're like why didn't you just put
that in the first place
yeah I hear that I felt the same way
maybe you're looking at from Disney's
perspective and Kevin Feige they are so
close they're like 45 million dollars
away the you can also look at it from
the angle why didn't they do it in the
initial release I think from the studio
perspective they really wanted endgame
to be the finality to be the final thing
that we kind of walk away from they
ended it with a funeral you know there
was no post-credit scene I think all of
us in this bubble are always worried
about what the next thing is and maybe
now they feel like okay that we've had
two months to move on let's rerelease it
people go see it anyway it's worth
seeing again in the theater it's such a
great cinematic experience let's do it
again
and now this will be the pivot
jumping-off point to what's coming in
phase four mm-hmm I mean it could
potentially help set up spider-man which
were right about to see that's true and
I just am really hoping that the deleted
scene that they put in is Tony Stark's
daughter Gibbs [ __ ] that I just died how
are you doing Kim she's like I want a
cheeseburger and it's like I love a good
cheeseburger but your dad just died
dude there was a hologram of him and his
Holograms are pretty vivid maybe she was
just confused didn't put like a coffin
out to the body guys which is why he
might be a scroll got you to buy an IMAX
ticket just to watch a kid cry well but
to be fair there is supposedly this
deleted scene of right after the snap
just like we saw Travis and Gomorrah in
you know the blood zone places where he
sees a grown-up version of his daughter
and they have some sort of exchange so
she probably isn't like the saddest
scene well I don't know saying goodbye
sounds like it would be really cheesy to
me I mean they did shoot it and that was
the actress who is the star of Netflix's
13 reasons why and that was a big that
was a big piece that like everyone's
like who's she gonna play what's cannon
and MCU - what she does and I was just a
little confused because I didn't I
didn't know what she looked like so when
a man's daughter was older I was like I
must be her so I was like I didn't know
you have blindness yeah just a little
bit more Southie he's Mark Wahlberg but
a little less yeah different flavors of
Southie yeah there was a thought that
maybe the funeral that we saw from Tony
Stark
should have also been doubled and given
the same proper respect to another
person who sacrificed their life Natasha
Romanov and we never saw any kind of
proper burial there was an argument over
whether to go back and use the stones to
try to save her but no proper send-off
so maybe that could be something
considering Black Widow has a movie in
the works maybe they're gonna try to set
that up and kind of explain with some
kind of scene that she is coming back or
there's a story that we never saw look
Buddhist one one thing that they say
that will be there and that potential
option is a new tribute to someone a lot
of people are guessing it could be Stan
Lee
but could be Black Widow do you guys
think get anybody else maybe that'd be
really cool I mean also the idea for the
tribute for the characters that are
leaving especially like your Scala
Johansson your opera diner and your
Chris Evans could be something that was
really cool but I think Stanley honestly
sounds like the best option if we wanted
a pay tribute to someone this that he
started at all for some reason everyone
at least in this country and around the
world knows that that guy made comics or
whatever that means you know like that's
a good paper yeah so at that idea like
before Captain Marvel that was kind of a
fun fun as the wrong word a heartfelt
tribute of having him in the Marvel
Studios logo but I wouldn't mind for
like the genuine end to this saga being
something for him I'd be kind of cool
what it was on Captain Marvel yeah yeah
which I think a lot of people are like I
don't know it felt weird that it was on
that movie and not on the big a final
one it was they did they did that with
Punisher and it's the end of season 2 he
goes and starts just murdering random
people and it says for Stanley it's just
watching from heaven like I do not
condone now before we get on to our next
topic which is about which major
Hollywood a-lister that I've been told
maybe I looked like sometimes is Danny
DeVito who might be joining the MCU we
just gotta give a quick thank you to our
sponsors who helped us bring this show
to you and asset and you know Devin is
very expensive to work with so they
helped us out a lot so thank you so much
to Harry's first of all the average guy
spent 3,000 hours of their life shaving
like literally four months of your of
your time they're shaving you do it all
at once and you get it done at the
beginning like the right drug dude so
basically you don't want to waste all of
your life's over paying for bad razors
with Harry's you get a razor that's so
sharp you don't have to shave as often
literally it's also only like two bucks
a blade I love using Harry's razors are
this I have to actually like inch in
with a very
sharp blade in order to get this just
right I literally grow hair like up to
my eyes and then I and then Harry's
brings it right back down to non
Neanderthal it's got this uh
weighted like rubber eyes handled it's
really great in your hand I don't know
if they're German factory is just like
pumping out by brainian blades or what
but they are very very sharp there's a
lot of band-aids on my neck that you
can't see I get a trial set from Harry's
that comes with everything you need for
a close comfortable shave
it's the weighted ergonomic handle for
an easy grip five blade razor with a
lubricating strip and trimmer blade for
a close shave
rich lathering shave gel that will leave
you smelling great
and a travel blade cover to keep your
razor dry and clean on the go a
listeners of our show by the way they
can redeem their trial set at Harry's
comm slash rock stars so make sure to go
to harrys.com slash rock stars to redeem
your offer and let them know I sent you
my name is Phillip and you're supporting
the show by being sent there thank you
so much also quick thank you to our
other sponsor molecule molecules
reimagining the future of clean air
starting with a air purifier with warm
weather comes allergy season sniffles
and sneezes and headaches and all the
annoying things that Eric does in the
office they're a part of our lives every
day during this part of you here
you can't get away from the allergens or
pollutants just by going inside because
actually indoor air is up to five times
as bad as outdoor air so luckily the
folks at molecule I've developed a cool
new kind of air purifier that eliminates
the things that make your nose all
stuffy which is why it sound like this
normally I would sound very masculine
it's cool it's got a sleek design it
uses his breakthrough nanotech that
actually destroys the allergens and
pollutants that are a thousand times
smaller than what a normal like HEPA
filter can do and also unlike a HEPA
filter the molecule actually destroys
the indoor air pollutants at a molecular
level it's like way to good tech to use
on this kind of thing but it completely
removes them from the air that you
breathe molecule uses it's called photo
electrochemical oxidation nanotech which
is the coolest thing to eliminate
viruses airborne chemicals also that
technology has been verified by science
as being very good at this but most
importantly it's been
tested by real people there's someone
who there's an allergy or like asthma
sufferer who said that she had not
breathe through her nose in 15 years
until she got the molecule which is
amazing like just for having a better
quality of life
so for $75 off your first order visit mo
l e ke u le comm and enter code
rockstars at check out again to save
money and breathe easier you just got to
go to molecule comm mo le ke u le comm
and enter code rockstars at checkout
thank you so much guys is Keanu gonna be
in the MCU okay so for those of you not
caught up on the latest Keanu news which
there's so much count in his lately I
Kevin Feige apparently he doesn't know
that every time he speaks it makes news
but he said recently that almost every
MCU movie they try to find a way to get
Keanu Reeves in there and it just hasn't
worked out but they're basically
implying that he's definitely gonna make
his way in at some point and since he's
having a moment right now it sounds like
they're trying extra hard to bring them
in so let's assume it's gonna happen
what Marvel character do we want Keanu
Reeves to play Adam warlocks right there
you know blonde I guess it's a question
what can't Keanu do I think he can I
mean he's that perfect fusion of someone
who is kind of weirdly the spiritual
figure from matrix roles and but he's
also kind of can be goofy in the way
that I would want Adam warlock to be and
James Gunn's third movie so I would love
if he could play out or something cosmic
like silver silver surfers the top of my
list but the same time with guardians
three coming out we're talking about
Adam warlock so I feel like the and they
also there was a hint of High
Evolutionary being they want to work
with the idea of using Keano in a way
that is cosmic and ethereal and
something that is just larger than life
it's not looking at like the Nitty
Gritty like street-level stuff in like
the MCU which would be cool to like if
you said like if either out they're like
maybe he was iron fist
or something like that I'd be like
that's that would be really cool I'd be
on board with that but the idea of him
playing someone like infinity or
something where it's like The Living
Tribunal cuz imagine him wearing like a
like a drape around its face in three
different phases of piano spinning
around and you talk to each one the idea
of him playing something larger than
life I feel kind of leans a little bit
into the mean culture now and I think
there's something there of the that
either they can kind of lean into his
like hand-to-hand combat which would be
cool but I think if Marvel really wanted
to mix it up which they're very good at
doing it's picking an ethereal roll from
like Silver Surfer or infinity someone
that is the embodiment of a concept in
the MCU which could be really fun to
like tackle as we move forward or you
know I don't know I think Silver Surfer
one because he look good and then two I
go infinity yeah which I just want to
see him running around in animal pelts I
just want to watch Keanu run around and
like that's like that character is kind
of yeah and that and like kind of like
that character I guess is so I want I
would like to see Keanu bring like his
humor kind of to it cuz it's not
normally like a humorous as much he
doesn't know he's funny like yeah and I
just I mean obviously always be my maybe
Keanu is yeah what flavor of Keanu are
we talking about are we talking about
maybe are we talking about Bill and Ted
Keanu we tell you matrix Keanu John wit
Keanu so one thing that it's going to be
an excellent adventure jokes bad jokes
bad joke no I mean it it probably they
wanted to be a John wick basically
damaged yeah honestly though if you go
down the rabbit hole of khang there's so
many versions of khang that you could do
like the young version of him you can
get an older version of you get the blue
version of them so many different ions
but if you have to go up against
multiple pianos in a scene one
hand-to-hand combat one with a laser one
with a fly a surfboard whatever you want
that's a pretty good pitch
real hard and you're also grading your
own pictures yeah I you guys went all
cosmic so I'm gonna go the other
direction I had already heard a rumor
that they wanted him for Wolverine but I
think that's good that he's aged out of
that if they don't want to have to
recast over rain again unless his old
man Logan on the Civil War yeah but the
whole throw out is finally like a
version of ghost rider I could get
behind
he does have similar energy to like Nick
Cage where he's just kind of like not a
person he's more of an idea he's a
hallucination that we all experience
together and are grateful for that I
think if you if you went the opposite
direction from cosmic something that's
as grounded as you can get like not like
an Iron Man or Captain America someone
just fully street-level someone also as
a teacher could be kind of cool like a
stick who trains daredevil something
like that would be very cool for him
yeah I just like that idea then I mean
he's a pretty good fighter as we saw
yeah I mean I kind of honestly before he
gets old I want to see him in some
badass fight scenes like I feel like if
there's MCU characters he could take
right now as Keanu Reeves like like you
might feel like supreme or something
like the cast Benedict Cumberbatch is
like great casting but you gotta imagine
Keanu was in consideration for that role
for something yeah for Tilda Swinton's
part maybe would aspire to that big I
just last pitch Galactus go fall like he
is the net like you want came the
conquer as your next villain Galactus
he's Laird he's deep sometimes he's a
hero son oh she's a villain and also
kind of giving him a weird costume I
feel like would really fit like another
flavor of Keanu
[Laughter]
theory but I think you know honestly I
think Silver Surfer is the one we're
gonna go with and also the idea also if
you kind of go with like he's silver
surfer and Galactus they're like a
symbiotic relationship where they both
kind of look like each other
going down a rabbit hole there's a
couple things like to get back to Spider
Man for just a moment
we didn't we're talking about how the
next Spider Man is coming on that
possibly could be a set up sort of
situation we don't know what movie they
want to hire in for is it gonna be a
Spider Man thing or is it gonna be a you
know like a guardians future thing or
whatever but jenna jameson well it
wouldn't be like a bugle would be more
like like a devil's Wears Prada style
magazine or something or like a
WikiLeaks dress what's the guy's name
[Music]
gonna be as well great my gratings down
below
alright well speaking of giving it a B
or so let's talk about the end of Game
of Thrones which I mean I'm gonna say
right out of the gate that I actually
have a lot that I liked in that in that
last season but clearly a lot of people
have a lot that they hated I had my own
frustrations but there's this really
popular video going around right now
from youtuber thinks story he reworked
the plots of the last three episodes of
the series in a way that a lot of people
are saying that they actually prefer and
wish the show had actually done it the
way he did it as if they had knew his
ending and also obviously he doesn't
need to keep george RR martin happy the
way that the rest of us do constantly or
he'll leave us
yeah but what he does is he leaves the
first two episodes of the season intact
and then he picks things up during the
Battle of Winterfell which still does
happen and Jorah and Theon still die but
then this is actually one of my favorite
changes the night king wins that battle
which I kind of like was I couldn't
imagine how the night king wasn't gonna
win and then he didn't but then our
survivors have to rush south to King's
Landing their Jaime has to convince
Cersei to let at all those people into
King's Landing and that's where she
makes Dany bend the knee to her Danny
obviously choosing her people well not
obviously I guess in this Americas and
her people does decide to bend the knee
and actually Cersei in that moment at
least kind of wins the game of Thrones
but bran also travels back in time and
he figures out that the only way to
destroy the night king is to burn the
weirwood tree where he was made it'll
kill all the magic in the world if they
do that including zombie Jon Snow the
father of Danny's baby who is definitely
pregnant with John's baby in this
version Danny does successfully burn the
tree for the good of the realm John dies
in her arms she's kind of an azure 'hi
figure in a way and then their child is
supposed to be the heir to the future
iron throne there's also some cool stuff
that we didn't see bran wargs into a
dragon which we all kind of wanted to
happen but it was only kind of teased
although he gets stuck in it when
somebody basically um plugs the dragon
arya does wear another face she was
Jaime Lannister's face and she uses it
to kill Cersei the night king freezes
the water around urine ships so cool and
olaria sand turns out she was still
alive in the red keep she breaks out of
her jail cell and gets him like a fight
with with arya basically maybe it's just
a shouting match or something but so
questions here basically just so you
guys are all caught up listeners are
caught up to does that sound more
satisfying to you would that have been
like yeah I would have been happy with
that version or is it kind of no matter
what at this point people were gonna
have issues I mean
well I guess so like the I mean I also
am kind of on the same page as you where
I didn't hate the last season of Game of
Thrones it I mean there was like some
things obviously that I was like that
wasn't great but like it's not my least
favorite thing in the world so I'm not
in that camp it's a high bar you know
well now I'd say I mean people are like
raging about this like friends with very
strong opinions that I have gotten into
a lot of battles with recently swords
only but yeah I guess that I just I
really thought that the night King was
gonna be a bigger deal because obviously
like it opens with the night King I mean
it opens with like the cold boys as I
call them haha
and like the night king and the cold
boys are supposed to represent like you
know Katie's band exactly the night King
and the cold boys but they're like
supposed to represent like climate
change and all of that kind of stuff and
so in my opinion what happened in the
game of Thrones
like series finale was kind of like they
were like oh yeah dude no it's cool like
climate change that problem we thought
we had that's done with let's just focus
on Donald Trump now and it's like that's
that's not the thing like there's the
the night king should have been a bigger
problem like that was the but for you
it's because of the allegory is kind of
no not necessarily just the allegory but
just in terms of like it was such a
bigger danger to everyone then Cersei
ever could be then any like human ever
could be which is more on the show right
the show really hyped it up to be yeah
so that was the thing that I agreed with
this guy's video on was that I did think
that the night king should have been a
little harder to defeat I'm also not a
huge fan of how literally every single
franchise now is bursting people into
Thanos dust it's like come on that was
Queen of the Damned 2001 era I wasn't
disappointed really with the season
either I think the more I think about it
I see the concerns I see the criticisms
and I think I'm good amount of them of
I like the idea of the night king
meaning more because like you said and
like you said like that just that the
way that went about for just a lot of
reasons I it felt Hollow it felt like we
were just kind of spinning our wheels
even though this is a big deal it didn't
feel that way so the idea of kind of
stretching that out and bring it further
south so that Cersei is aware of what
this problem is that's great and I like
the idea of utilizing making the
faceless men mean literally anything
like for anyone like besides heard arias
training as an assassin the idea that
she learned this trick that is amazing
that is essential for the story yeah for
the overall so that it means something I
like the the his videos great I like the
way he kind of breaks in a certain
points specifically like just utilizing
every everything that you've set up
beautifully over all these seasons and
making it worth something
not that I again still enjoyed the end
of the the end of the series but I like
that idea I like the idea of Dany having
the bending knee and I liked that there
was just I like that this ending better
for Dany and Jon specifically although I
think the showrunners brought Danny to
an interesting spot that we're kind of
seeing for a long time so her ending I'm
not so much upset about but I do like
their ending for Jon better or I like
this this man's fan theory about Jon's
and ultimate ultimate sacrifice also the
weirwood tree meaning something you know
a lot more also a brand meaning I will
call out that the weirwood tree is a
MacGuffin like in his version you know
it does mean more but it also suddenly
becomes a race to the weirwood tree in
his version the night king is able to
see the same thing that brain is able to
see and so now they are all racing to
the weirwood tree which does have kind
of an Indiana Jones feel to it a little
bit but you're right that the show had
already established like this location
isn't really important these symbols are
really important maybe they're all
pointing to that yeah I like this guy's
video and I think the reason I liked it
is he's very tapped into what a lot of
the fans saw the show as like he kind of
follows a lot of the plot trajectory
points that we kind of predicted the
show would might go in the final season
and instead Dany Dave subverted
expectations which a lot of fans are
just mad that all they did is just be
surprising and just give us something
unexpected even though it's not really
justified in the show's trajectory up
until that point but I think the fact
that I like it is it doesn't
and it's what the show should have been
you know like just because they're
tapped in with what fans won for the
show doesn't mean it's right and there's
a lot of things that I saw in this video
where I'm like oh god I would hate it if
like hilarious and I did not need a
Laureus it was rich so it's not like
this guy is any wiser or the fans or any
wiser than Dan and Dave are but I think
the reason why people are upset is
unlike what you saw the Russo brothers
in Kevin Feige did with Avengers and
Gaiman kind of satisfy exactly what fans
want like the Marvel guys are very
plugged into what fans are expecting and
much much better at expectation
management then what the HBO team was at
and I think going forward with a lot of
these big property things that it sets
the bar higher you have to be aware of
what your fans are expecting and you
can't just throw curve balls at them and
expect them to stay with you you kind of
have to you have to watch some of these
videos you have to know what fans want
from these characters rather than just
kind of blindly go in your own direction
and expect everyone to be on board with
you and then just say f you if they
aren't on board right can you imagine if
Stanley
years ago told Kevin Feige how Avengers
endgame needs to end like that's the
that's the big difference right they
they were like we can do what the fans
want and we can get we can build to it
and we can pay that all off and instead
you know D&D we were given a very
specific ending with characters and and
this version that this guy did does not
acknowledge you know the things that
George or Martin most likely told them
this is how it's supposed to end so he
does have that freedom first of all that
that our show runners did not but I do
think Eric's really tapped into this
this idea of the fan service kind of
ending I think endgame nailed it
but I do think that's maybe my issue
with this video is it's kind of like
yeah you know as the rubble is falling
like a Laureus and kind of falls out of
the row boys like oh thank god I'm out
of there let's fight excessive that said
you know sometimes that's the feeling
that people want when Sam and I were on
SourceFed the last video we did was just
purposely like the most fanservice a
thing of any single reference that I've
ever been made on SourceFed and it's
like some really cheesy kind of story
but it really was kind of like this it
really
already lost their jobs at that point
you really didn't care like for like
what our ending was it was like why
don't we make literally like the ending
that the fans probably would request
it's just man they were just in a real
hard position especially now that people
are like here's how you should have done
it with a lot of hindsight and with a
lot of reaction telling me how you
should have done it yeah it's a lot
easier to do it but still hey good job
right yeah Sam what do you greatest
[ __ ] alright that's me oh that's an A
grade my pitched thank you great my
[ __ ]
that's pitch with the P let's give it up
really quick for another sponsor who
helped us bring you guys this new show
it's wicks wicks allows you guys to
build professional websites with
thousands of different templates so your
site can do whatever it needs to do it
can be a blog a business a place to
interact with your fans of your pop
culture YouTube channel which is
actually what we did with it I'll tape
up that in a second but basically uh Wix
just has a bunch of professional
solutions to fit whatever your needs are
so the way we used it we built this
interactive website for you to get
involved with what we cover on like this
show and in our other videos it's new
rockstars fan comm and lets you give us
feedback and suggests feature video
topics for us to cover it helps us by
the way you get a direct line of
communication with you guys of what we
should spend our time on the newly
launched version of waste it's got this
Wix turbo it loads way faster than other
websites they take care of the heavy
lifting that lets you just give it a
full creative control of your own
website that could be your first website
you could be an experienced veteran
designer like Devin but you can get
started today no one lasts because we
all respect Devin very much and all the
amazing things that Devin was pulled off
again give it up for Devin for
everything different pulls off costly
he's literally holding up the table
right now so you can get started today
for free at wix.com slash rockstars and
apply code rockstars at checkout to get
an additional 10% off when you upgrade
to the premium version so again it's
wicks calm slash rockstars and if you
use the code rockstars to check out you
get 10% off the upgraded version of
premium but also just starting is free
but
let's move on to some movies that we
didn't connect with as much as we do
with our new website so the it's a real
strange time for movies actually that
are not MCU movies like MC news is still
you know killing it or coming back
because they're doing so well with the
same movies but both x-men Dark Phoenix
and men and black international they
completely failed to connect with
critics and audiences they're both
sitting in the low 20s on Rotten
Tomatoes Dark Phoenix this is totally
true was beaten at the box office by
Secret Life of pets too so I just want
to go down really quick and ask let's
start with you Whitney why didn't you
watch men and black international I
guess I just like I didn't I don't know
honestly it was just one of those things
for me was like okay well like we know
Will Smith's not coming back and then I
know she's not really been interested in
since like 1998 to be honest in a minute
no but I I do appreciate that there's a
small a small pug cameo I've heard I
would see it for that I have a baby pug
so that interests me on a deep not the
300 million dollars they spent on
creating new species you could just look
up pug pictures on Instagram why would I
do that go pay six dollars to see it at
my local theater $6 just a matinee or
something
dumbly inexpensive of course you do it
was okay so why didn't you take tenth
friends your again and again you're
right also fun plug I saw Dark Phoenix
too and the the final fight scene you
like hans zimmer weirdly did the score
show okay it's pretty good and it's like
chug and chug and chug it you hit that
low first thing like are we gonna make
it it's quiet you're like whoa the beat
still going and then I start flashing
and was like oh the fire alarms going
off but it's been closed off for maybe
ten minutes and they did he says he was
a press screening they didn't know what
to do cuz we're pressed and they can't
show us another screening so they
evacuated the other theater and left us
in then as the alarm was going off I
already had my opinion of the movie it
wasn't gonna change men and black I
don't know it's it kind of misses the
mark of the the charm of the first men
in black film and also the fun discovery
of it where it it taps into all the UFO
UFO gee that we are kind of aware of
like the tabloids and like crop circles
and everything like it it's great like
and then the second movie happens the
third one and whatever and the fourth
one you're like okay we could you know
new director if you're a new new team
maybe we can figure it out and it
doesn't it has three ideas and nothing
ends and then the movies over and it's
it's a real big disappointment this
really interesting of a you reminded me
of the first one it is the connections
to Roswell
right and it's this even the trailer for
it is like basically what if I told you
that there's this whole underground
society that is like the most advanced
force in the universe and it's all like
right under your nose happening every
day and also people around you every day
are blatant aliens and that's why
there's so many weird people the planet
so it did have that whole other layer
and then it eventually became like a
full version of that will spend music
video Erik why didn't you come to my
birthday party was just a marketing for
the movies so bad no I mean here's the
problem it is marketing right like
there's been plenty of movies that like
don't get great critics reviews
like audiences still love that I think
venom is a good example of that like
critics didn't go crazy for venom but it
made a ton of money and audience is
still connected in a Asian market we're
made yeah it's a lot of it is again
expectation management these are two
dead franchises like the last movies
that people could remember from those
franchises were not good people didn't
like x-men apocalypse I don't think
people could really remember men in
black 3 but I don't think people really
had a positive feeling about it and the
studio's didn't do anything to get
people excited to go see these movies
like part of it was Fox is brought out
by Disney so Fox executives didn't
really know how to promote Dark Phoenix
at that point but no the trailers were
confusing for both of those movies were
released at really confusing times like
I remember yeah one it was in the middle
of the night yeah it was like a 9:00
p.m. West Coast time for a Dark Phoenix
trailer I'm like dude they want people
to watch this trailer men and black came
out like it was like Friday like right
before Christmas and like we were on our
way out the door we're like oh should we
talk about this like there's there's
yeah the studios and both cases dumb -
these movies and didn't want people to
go see them it seemed like so why should
we pray Z because I get why x-men kind
of faltered because weirdly we know so
much about the merger of two companies
and we talk about it you know like not I
like talking about it but how many how
much everybody kind of knows about it in
like some way or another the men and
black movies it's weird because you had
a chance to kind of reinvigorate it you
had a young co-stars that were great in
a hit movie Endor Ragnarok and all you
really had to do was do a buddy cop
movie and it's none of those things
well they it seems like they kind of
tried to do a little bit about the
marketing but then the marketing kept
changing where then they said well what
if it's actually a Thor spin-off right
there was like all the references to the
hammer they made like yeah two ads that
were dedicated to making it seem like a
fun game yeah yeah it is a business and
yeah on the script level the direction
level these movies aren't that great
either but you can still like you can
salvage it and make something great out
of it and I didn't see minibike but the
reason I didn't see it is it seemed to
have not understand what was great about
the original film which is amazing the
original film the whole joke of it is
you have like Will Smith get emasculated
this tiny noisy cricket right it's funny
and goofy you so good yeah what's his
face like yeah and then the guy
cockroach guy d'Onofrio's doing these
crazy wacky like bits that as the series
went on they got further and further
away from it and tried to learn it into
the cool and then in the men in black
international they literally have huge
guns and that's all that's cool about it
as opposed to the small guns vibe
remember like just the end of the the
credits sequence is one that always
stays with me right where like it keeps
zooming back out and we just kind of
like understand like how like quirky and
weird the universe is and how
insignificant some things are reminded
me a lot of that show pushing daisies
it's just kind of like this like quirky
like weird reality and it's almost like
the in that show the joke of being able
to like resurrect people and it's like
in a bakery or to make it's like putting
that just accepts a position of super
serious content with like super silly
cute portrayal of it and that you know
men in black that's kind of the theme of
that right where you know the whole
universe and everything supporting can
be like in a child's toy I think it was
right it was a marble marble and also
it's like it's day-to-day for Tommy Lee
Jones it's like yeah the world ends like
every like couple months it's fine don't
freak out if you freak out it's gonna
make it so hard for you right don't
freak out and then they yeah they like
you pointed out they kind of just lose
that over three and four they don't care
anymore you know what they also didn't
have I we were always obsessed with the
and then like the little aliens in the
face yeah I always imagined like anyone
that it was a teacher of mine or
whatever like they had that little alien
inside of them but all of these
innovative ways to like hide aliens
amongst us and then I don't think there
was any reveals of like new kind of
aliens in the in the commercials or
anything no they didn't they they did do
that same joke from the first one where
it was like it's like Michael Jackson
alien and then they showed Donald Glover
is like yeah a guy's name and it's like
and everyone's like yeah for sure
because he's talented like I don't
understand yeah do you guys remember
Burger King putting out
the men in black it was like the it was
like a chicken applesauce and it was
green and it was like for like the
aliens you remember that Apple like it
was it wasn't applesauce it was like a
like a dressing it was like a condiment
almost but it was lime green and it
tasted kind of like apples and then you
dip your chickpeas and do it this is a
rick sanchez argument you want to shut
us off before we move on from it though
I do want to ask you guys kind of a
two-parter here with x-men Dark Phoenix
why why did fatigue sit in for that
franchise and out for the Avengers and
then ask someone else was like I mean
output right like of interest was
pumping out two to three movies a year
and keeping these characters fresh in
our mind you think that it's because
they had more movies yeah I honestly do
yeah I mean it wasn't we forgot what the
x-men franchise was the x-men apocalypse
kind of came out and landed with a thud
in the summer of 2016 and we had almost
three years before we had another x-men
movie with that character we had
Deadpool movies that were doing great
but I think people lost touch with what
that franchise was and the fact that
x-men apocalypse ended with it was such
a not great movie like no one really
cared what was coming next from that I
mean Days of Future past was the one
before that and it was solid I guess we
had Logan but Logan was so removed from
everything else from that franchise and
was deliberately trying to be its own
thing and I think a lot of people felt
that Logan should have been the end of
that franchise because it was just such
an emotional goodbye to those characters
so it kind of felt like you were
resurrecting something that we had
already said goodbye to and also kind of
piggybacking off that like x-men
apocalypse set up a whole new cast that
no one connected with no one remembers
who they are like I know Cyclops wears
the goggles and my car lair is blue and
like that's it and like then they did
like this new movie it's like well you
guys like those characters so they
the main crux of this movie specifically
even though we already had about three
endings to this franchise so yeah and
also like saying like they that Marvel
MCU proper cranks out so many movies
like it does work though it does work
especially when you're leading to
something very specific it was still
able to bring in new people and keep
loyal fans going back over and over
again Captain Marvel but made a billion
dollars almost million dollars something
like that so it's it's a it's a
testament to that and a few other things
but it does help having movies crank out
that often ever since
like after Days of Future past I guess
I've just kind of been feeling like a
sense of fatigue from Jennifer Lawrence
and Michael Fassbender
I mean she's giving that office yeah
like she just wants out so bad and like
neither of them care you know and it's
just like I know you don't care I don't
want to watch this movie that you don't
even care about either he doesn't even
wear a costume in this movie that's but
that's an interesting point about the
endings that you Sam and Eric said that
this idea that it felt like it ended
already
it kinda reminds you that Lord of the
Rings style of ending right whereas kind
of Return of the King where it was like
everyone needed to go to the bathroom
I still remember that because I had to
see a doctor after this and it was just
like oh you have to hold it through
three or four more endings and it does
have the x-men franchise like reminding
you the Patrick Stewart generation of
that franchise ended once you know like
we have ended that thing so many times
meanwhile Avengers has never they just
got to their first ending 65 years later
yeah and to be fair to the x-men
franchise Avengers they learned from the
mistakes of the x-men franchise I mean
Kevin Feige was a associate producer in
the first one and he was able to see
where the x-men franchise kind of went
wrong over the years and was able to
from the beginning do like a 2.0 version
of superhero genre movies and was able
to do exactly the story he wanted to
when was able to plan ahead and the way
that the x-men movies have been able to
they've been kind of reacting to the
failures of the past one trying to do a
different thing you know by bringing
back the exact same creative team almost
every super weird cool but and then
what's gonna what's it gonna take for
you guys to get excited about the x-men
Kevin Feige PGA on the opening credits
yeah and you think time probably like
not even if it was next year even if it
was Kevin Feige even if those Marvel it
probably is like kind of it just doesn't
feel right right now to do it you say
that but they cranked out they the third
spider-man 2 is coming out in a week and
so and they have not waited at any time
just to keep making those movies but
when you stand MCU on there people got
interested again spider-man homecoming
didn't perform as well as like previous
spider-man films but it still made
buckets of money and it got people to go
see a lot of more movies since Tom
Holland was in those so that idea of
like the if you I'd say give it a little
bit of time just cuz retired they
probably hired make an x-men movies give
it a second and we retired
give it some time but I think you don't
have to wait that long I've been really
satisfied with all of the like x-men
characters that they've been introducing
through Deadpool like Sonic teenage
warhead anyone fly I like her a lot of
your own like shout out like she fly we
like her now like if I think the
Deadpool is gonna get me back into it I
mean it seems like it's the only one
that they'll keep right yeah cool well
we're gonna wrap this up with a thing
we're just gonna try out here it's a
just a little bit of rogue questions on
this rogue theory show and these
questions are I don't know I don't know
what the questions are actually alright
so I'll probably hate them but uh but
we'll see maybe they make sense maybe
they're great maybe they're amazing
Devin you did a great job I'm sure okay
alright so number one concern it's out
to everyone so Steven Spielberg is
producing a short form horror series
called Spielberg after dark that can
only be viewed when it is literally dark
outside question
besides horror what other content should
you only watch at night Oh at the Battle
of Winterfell so that you can actually
make out the contrast line
the opening scene to Logan where he
takes out all those guys on the side of
the freeway
super bloody and it's it so that we even
hide your tears of your crime
[Music]
[Applause]
Bladerunner 2049 director Dennis V new
is creating a dune spin-off TV series
focused on the women of the dune
universe question what alien race needs
their own spinoff series so as a team I
give the Scrolls maybe this girl Scrolls
maybe you could shape-shift and go out
and do fun stuff together I think we
need an Animorph hork Bashir Chronicles
series and you've been saying they've
been primed for a reboot why hasn't it
happened yet yeah no sure okay I'm on it
number three a video went viral this
week of a man washing his roof in
Florida during a rainstorm dressed in a
full spider-man costume cushion Eric
when did you make it down to Florida hey
you guys said I wasn't allowed to do it
naked so number four Netflix said that
30 million accounts watched the new Adam
Sandler movie 30 million accounts the
new Adam Sandler movie murder mystery in
its very first weekend
Whitney why did he watch this instead of
men and black okay fine
did anybody watch it 30 million people
did that card landed perfectly on her
wallet
teetering up there yeah 30 million I
mean is it are they Russian BOTS like
what I heard it was okay yeah people
love Sam Lane my dad my dad watch it
like five times
alien spin-off series I need to see xxx
sense but fans in Edmonton Canada have
started a petition to name a park
building the nathan fillion civilian
pavilion alright there's a challenge
round first person to come up with their
own great celebrity rhyming name of a
building wins
some examples are Frances McDormand
McDermott or II or winning but Whitney
van landingham's man landing pad okay
I've got the the Janet Reno clambake
Casino Casino Whitney wins this episode
of a great job thank you so much that's
it guys that was the premiere episode
it's a big thanks to our panel we got
Erik Voss Sam basher stupid answers and
might be awesome and our winner of this
week follow all these people on Twitter
and on Instagram I give them a search
give them a Google thanks so much also I
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
thanks so much for going out on a limb
with us on this show we're trying new
things obviously and we're really proud
of the stuff we've done but also we're
really excited about the stuff that
we're gonna do a constructive criticism
allowed at FEMA on Twitter I have a good
one guys thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]